what up space fam goes in here from
anime outpro back at it again to discuss
the latest and craziest developments in
the one piece story and wow this is a
crazy chapter you know about some of it
if you saw my earlier spoiler video but
there's so much more here now that we
have the full translated Pages not only
Zorro's dad and his devil fruit but also
the world has already gotten wind of
what happened in wano and as a result
the new Emperors and their new bounties
have already been published in the
papers earlier than expected so make
sure to stay tuned for this one if you
do enjoy these traps reviews and want to
keep them coming Channel packing with it
and smash that like button to trigger
the wano celebration fireworks and yes
YouTube has indeed added fireworks to
celebrate wano's Liberation pretty cool
of them remember always be a smashing
pirate king and never be a passing
Orochi if you haven't make this video
you join The Knockout by subscribing and
hitting that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications so you don't miss
future one piece videos and updates and
now without further Ado let's jump into
its spoilers and all we start in the
Holy Land of marijua as the elders speak
of the sun god Nica finally emerging two
Emperors falling and they admit they
won't be able to cover this up the whole
world will latch on this news things are
getting so crazy furthermore they say
the timing could not be worse they don't
know how to deal with the situation an
elder is shown sweating clearly Oda is
showing that the world government is in
a very bad position right now and after
Luffy beat the strongest creature in the
world and the yonko with the highest
Bounty I feel like the world government
will be willing to work with Blackbeard
to try to take Luffy AKA sun god Nika
down after all Blackbeard was a warlord
and the world government needs as much
help as they can get right now nothing
guaranteed but it's a hunch I have that
the world government will join forces
with the Blackbeard Pirates since Nika
presents such a threat to their very
existence and kuzan already being with
the Blackbeard Pirates may be a clue
that this will happen as well but for
now we jump back to this chapter as they
mentioned the elephant is gone aka
zunisha the elders discussed that the
Border are staying closed for now so
wano is still almost impenetrable good
move Momo why open wano before the world
is safe it makes more sense that Momo
Waits until Luffy succeeds in his
Warrior of Liberation Mission which we
all know will include taking down the
current world government even the five
Elders give props to Momo by saying that
at least one of them has considerable
guile for not opening the borders PS
guile means cutting intelligence so no
one has to look it up in other words
Momo is Big Brain confirmed which is
good to be when you want to rule a
country the elders still want Robin and
the cp0 agent says that yes he can still
have her brought so it ain't over yet
even if they don't plan on taking juano
now they'll still try for Robin then
their signal is hijacked and someone
tells them to stay where they are and
he's on his way we'll find out who this
is later but suffice to say it's one of
the most high possibilities you can
imagine back to wano for now and the
news of Momo's Victory is being met with
happiness after 20 years of tyranny we
see Hawkins who does not look good in
Drake Too Drake brings up the cards of
Prophecy and how hawkins's cards said
he'd be safe if he stuck with kaido but
that's not the case first Hawkins brings
up what seems to be his own regret he
explains that he submitted to kaido
because he didn't want to die but Ken
and his crew fought at a better end and
were prepared to die ironically though
kids succeeded and lived while Hawkins
looks like he might be dying right here
Hawkins reveals that when he said there
was one percent chance of a certain
person surviving he was talking about
himself then he falls down suggesting he
may be dead we'll see what happens here
but yeah gotta respect kid and how he
was ready to die and ended up succeeding
and his side took down to yonko
Meanwhile Hawkins joined the side that
seemed to guarantee survival and yet he
ended up getting hurt worse than kid and
might even be dead now if I read this
correctly at one point I'm guessing he's
saying even when he knew that kaido
wouldn't win he didn't want to crawl
back to kid so he did have some pride
he's not like Apu who just jumps back
and forth like a kangaroo doesn't matter
what's going on doesn't matter how many
times she has to jump back and forth
still out of those three you gotta
respect kid the most I love that red
hair dude we jump forward seven days
Momo decreed there will be another
Festival history lessons are on their
way and they are teaching the kids about
Odin this is cool because before they
were being brainwashed by kaido and
aroshi approved education material but
now they can reclaim their true history
it's true what they say history is
written by The Victors and Oda is
showing that right here it's clear as
I've been saying that we've been
witnessing history in the making and now
the kids know about how hiri and denjiro
remain loyal and continue to help the
cause all this time Luffy also gets
credit described as a warrior known as
Joy boy they are under the impression
that he's no longer in the country
though Luffy's heroism is compared to
the legendary god of the blade
shimotsuki Ruma one of Zorro's famous
look-alikes and ancestors here in the
title of Sword God and slayed dragons at
the Eternal graves in Ringo they're
building another Shrine on a hill over
looking to flower Capital just like the
god of the blade Zuma there it is again
they are emphasizing zoro's ancestor
twice in a short period of time now make
sure to remember this for what happens
later in the chapter because it will be
very important kinemon and kalmatsu
speak about how they will put Odin to
rest here and Surround him with his
allies including yasu other daimyo and
ending with Ashura and izo who Sally
didn't make it out of the war alive I
think this was a good move by Oda
lending weight and significance to the
war by actually having some relevant
characters not make it through and I
really thought easel was very cool so
this does hit considerably harder than
just some extras dying we see onimaru
and kalamatsu petsim as he wonders if
they'll be honored by being buried here
one day I love to see Marco still here
too as kinemon asks him if it's cool to
bury ezo here Marco says of course it's
only right that his final resting place
is in his home country he remarks that
it seems like he's been left behind once
again to say goodbye this really
emphasizes how many people Marco has
lost but at least this war ended with
their Victory Komatsu and kinemon are
really feeling being the ones who remain
aka the ones who survived two and
kinemon says that if any more of their
Heroes go he doesn't think he could take
it he says let us pray for their good
health a very nice moment there we then
jump to Yamato who is clearly hungry but
not eating we later find out why and I
really like the reason and respect
Yamato all the more for it but first we
get news that Luffy and Zoro have opened
their eyes so glad to see them back and
doing so good so soon it's impressive
that they only needed seven days to
recover after everything they've been
through I love how Luffy screams out
meat and Zoro screams out booze I'm
having a beer right now just to
celebrate along with Zorro cool to see
them waking up at the same time as well
keep in mind we're still waiting to find
out what that death figure that appeared
before Zoro was but we don't get an
explanation yet Momo tells him to save
some room because he wants to do another
huge Country-Wide banquet and he's been
waiting for them to wake up to do it
that's awesome and yeah chances are what
Luffy wants is to have such a banquet at
the end of the story but worldwide
rather than just Countrywide I love
seeing Yamato hugging Luffy while he
eats it's so cute and Chopper hugs Zorro
that's adorable too the two don't
recognize Momo at first but say he looks
pretty strong and they want to crack at
him which is hilarious to say while
they're still supposed to be recovering
Momo tries to use his old tricks again
and tries to see comfort from nami's
chest like before but this time he gets
punched he reminds her that he still ate
but it doesn't look like that excuse
will fly anymore and Sanji and Brooke
love it saying welcome to adulthood no
more special privileges for you remember
they were super jealous of him before so
now they couldn't be more happy about
him losing out on those privileges then
Yamato says he's a child inside but
outside he's basically Odin pretty big
words coming from a wannabe Odin Yamato
even puts plates on Momo's head to make
him look more like Odin Yamato assures
the annoyed Momo that he'll be the
number one Samurai in 101 day and he
should thank his parents for his strong
body Nami invites Yamato to take a bath
with her now that her vigil has ended
and it's explained that in wano it's
accustomed to give up something until
your prayers are answered by the gods
Yamato swore not to eat or bathe until
Luffy and Zoro recovered which is super
touching I don't know if Yamato needed
to throw in the bathing part but it's
still super touching Luffy brightens up
saying Yama bro that must be why I feel
so great so cool Luffy and Zoro for
their part were kept clean by ladies and
Sanji is very jealous I really like how
they bring up the words exchanged
between Sanji and Zoro during their
fights since that could have easily been
dropped and ever mentioned again but
here's our incorporates it for a joke
saying oh yeah I must have returned from
the dead to fulfill my promise of
killing usanji but Sanji says I don't
need your help with that anymore still
we see Zoro is well enough to wield his
swords and joke around with Sanji which
again I'm super impressed by these
guys's recovery is remarkable and Amato
joins the man's bath to Sanji Brooke and
Momo's great pleasure we won't show the
woman's bath because we want to stay
monetized but suffice to say Nami is
looking very good and I can't wait to
see her animated usop and Frankie
meanwhile were getting their ships ready
to sail as the other crews are admiring
Frankie's Mecca kid tells them not to
get to Buddy Buddy they can't let their
guards down until they're safely back at
Sea he knows the info will leak and with
the emperor's gone they're gonna have
the biggest Targets on their backs and
law agrees while his crew speculates how
Law's Bounty will be raised by an
unthinkably large amount this is what I
love Oda knows how much we love bounties
and he's really hyping it up all the
more here by even having characters in
the story get hyped over it Apu and his
number are here too you know he switches
sides so not surprising he didn't go
down with kaido APU acts like he doesn't
know how it was leaked but says it was
leaked while in actuality it is obvious
to the others that he leaked the
information himself and then it's too
good to be true he actually has the
newspaper with the new bounties he drops
it in front of kid as if that wasn't
good enough he also mentions that their
updated bounties and the names of those
who have been newly dubbed Emperors of
the sea are there there is more of a
focus on kid than law here and if you
watch my new generation of yonkovid then
you know it's probably because kid is
gonna be a new yonko so Oda is signaling
him out specifically right here a laugh
about poo leaked false information and
he takes full credit for beating kaido
but that's hopefully not gonna happen
then the other hype moment very hype
moment happens we see Admiral greenbull
in the sky with wano up ahead flying
using a kind of flower helicopter coming
from his back this is huge I did think
his powers were plant-based before
because he didn't eat for three years
and he is associated with the color of
green like plants this implied that he
may use photosynthesis and doesn't need
to actually eat here it is clear that
his powers are in fact related to play
plants although we don't know the
specifics it could even be a mythical
Zone like a fairy King fruit think of
King from the seven deadly sins we'll
see what it is but it is hype because we
know how strong the Admirals are and you
can bet this last one to be revealed
won't disappoint also if you didn't know
in all likelihood he's zoro's dad I
explained this in more detail near the
end of my Zorro's father and his devil
fruit explained video link in the
description long story short we had two
mentions of zoro's ancestor here in this
chapter I speak of course of the god of
the blade Ruma then Zoro woke up and now
his likely dad is coming towards him I
cannot wait to see how this Zoro Focus
Arc wraps up for him and I'm so glad
after he shines so much already Oda is
still giving him more of a focus like
this to me all of this is clearly
leading up to green ball being Zorro's
father another joke people were making
in the previous video was that green
bull like Zoro would get lost on his way
to wano and it does seem like his people
are worried about this as they say tell
me your exact position be more specific
sounds like they're dealing with someone
who tends to get lost to me anyways
that's it for this one and what a one it
was tell me is green Bulls oro's father
does he tend to get lost what is his
true power and finally will he help or
hinder the straw hats it's such an
exciting time to be a one-piece fan and
if you are one and enjoy this review
Channel pirate king within and smash
that like button to set out the YouTube
fireworks to celebrate wano's Liberation
and Zorro's father-son reunion if you
haven't make this the video you join the
Knock Em Up by subscribing and this is
crucial hit that notification Bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and updates
and while you wait for the next chapter
that will hopefully tell us the exact
bounties of the straw hats now and the
new Emperors feel free to check out my
new Bounty prediction for Zorro the
video is linked on screen right now as
is my one piece playlist that includes
videos on Luffy's new bound t on the
Admirals on the Supernova and much more
Choose Your Own Adventure here and until
next time see ya Space Cowboys